so after my last video on grip strength
training at 4 I'm training quite a few
people asked me to do a video in future
on vascularity training this is that
video so here I'm gonna be looking at
how you get that really cool roadmap
like look of veins running up and down
your arms and also whether or not this
has any performance benefits so without
further ado let's get into it this is
how you can increase your vascularity
all aboard the vein train wish I hadn't
done that so the first thing you can do
in order to increase the appearance of
vascularity is to reduce your body fat
so if you can reduce the subcutaneous
fat that sits just below the skin then
they'll be less in between your skin and
your blood vessels so they'll pop more
and be much more visible at the same
time you also need to build more muscle
building more muscle not only means that
you require more blood to be delivered
to that part of your body at the same
time you'll also be pushing the veins up
because you've got the muscle underneath
pushing the veins up through the skin on
top there's a genetic component to
vascularity some people are just gonna
look more vascular than others also the
thickness of your skin play the role so
if you've got thinner skin then you're
gonna look more vascular and that's why
older guys tend to look more vascular
than younger guys so a lot of it is bad
news as you get older it becomes hard at
the build muscle easy to put on fat
there is some good news you should also
look more vascular this of course is
partly why Stallone looks so incredibly
ripped with all those veins it's also a
look that really works for Hugh Jackman
as Wolverine so he says something to
look for stew in terms of fitness as you
get older so that's the boring stuff
that's the stuff you already know
obviously by losing body fat building
muscle you're gonna look more vascular
just by exercising you're looking more
vascular some people say that you need
to be 10 percent or lower to look really
veiny I personally disagree because I'm
probably well I'm definitely more than
10 percent body fat and probably 15 or
higher and my forearms look fairly
vascular so you don't need to go that
far but there's gonna be like a say
genetic component and some other factors
at play some of those factors
fortunately are things that are
negotiable and that's what we're
interested in so my first tip is going
to be train your forearms I just did a
video all about four on training grip
strength training
the reason for this is that the forearms
store less fat the skin there is thinner
and also of course this is the visible
part of your body so if you're not
trading it for arms which a lot of
people don't then you're missing out on
the opportunity to have that really
great vascular look right where it
counts because when a lot of people say
they want to look more vascular what
they're really talking about is their
forearms and to a lesser extent their
biceps so train your forearms build
those muscles big and you'll push the
veins in your forearms towards the
surface and you're also direct more
blood flow down to there so if you're
not ready for on training make sure
that's in your routine and another tip
is to take creatine and the reason for
this is that when you take creatine you
increase the water retention in the
muscle not in the skin so this means
once again that the muscles will swell
and that will push those veins up
towards the surface this is a very easy
hack anyone can do it and it should
increase your vascularity at least it's
a little bit whilst water retention in
the muscles is a good thing water
retention under the skin subcutaneous
water retention is of course a bad thing
so we want to reduce this because it's
adding more of a layer between your
veins and arteries and the visible
surface of your skin
counter-intuitively the way that you
reduce water retention is to drink more
water that's because when you're
dehydrated your body thinks needs to
hold on to water and thus it stores it
underneath the skin when you're drinking
plenty of water it has a kind of
flushing effect and you look more ripped
as a result this is why it's really
important to stay hydrated if you want
to look your best and as it happens most
people in America and the UK go about
being chronically dehydrated all the
time most of us aren't getting enough
water so for all sorts of reasons not
just vascularity for your general health
it's really important to keep drinking
lots of water and make sure that you're
doing that but part of what you came
here to find out is whether or not
vascular if you can be trained or more
specifically is there a kind of training
that will increase your vascularity and
the good news is that yes there is so
basically this has to do with vascular
smooth muscle and this has the job of
dilating and constricting our blood
vessels as well as moving them towards
the surface of your skin and then
burrowing them back deep depending on
whether it's hot or cold Jeff Cavaliere
has a great video explaining this so
when you're very hot your body will push
those blood vessels up towards the
surface in order to keep you cool and
when you're very cold it will burrow
them back deep in order to warm
back up so if it's very warm you're
going to look more vascular than if it's
very cold so if you train your
thermoregulation by taking contrast
showers or just going in the sauna this
could actually help you to look more
vascular by training that aspect
interesting Lee Saunders have also been
shown to improve your ability to
thermoregulate and thereby enhanced
performance during endurance tasks
making you able to run for much longer
or perform any other exercise for much
longer before fatiguing and tiring out
because you're not overheating as much
what's more interesting though is that
this muscle tissue is also responsible
for increasing your localized blood
pressure and thereby directing blood
flow so if you do lots of bicep curls
then constriction will occur in the
blood vessels in order to direct more
blood more oxygen more nutrients to
those muscles as they need it and this
is partly responsible for hypertrophy
and it's also why you look really
vascular when you're performing reps and
of course it's what gives us the pump so
it follows and this is what Jeff
Cavaliere recommends that by doing high
rep ranges you can direct more blood
flow to those muscle groups and increase
your vascularity if you workout by
chasing the pump like a bodybuilder with
higher reps lower weights then this
could increase your vascularity this is
something makes a lot of sense to me
like I say I've got a relatively high
body fat but I still look quite vascular
and find someone who chases the pump in
pretty much every workout likewise I've
seen Stallone training he's very
vascular and he seems to Train in a
similar way like a bodybuilder with high
rep ranges lots of effort what happens
if you don't want to train with
lightweights and go for high rep ranges
not everybody likes that kind of
training if it's not part of your
strength training protocol then I do
have a solution and that is to use drop
sets
I love drop sets I think they're
massively underrated I think they useful
for all kinds of things so drop set of
course means that you're training to
failure with a heavy weight and then as
soon as you reach failure instead of
giving up you simply take a lighter
weight and then when you can't do any
more of that you lighten the weight
again with very miniscule break in
between thereby ensuring that the blood
is still pulling in the muscle that the
pause isn't long enough to lose that
pump and that way you get the benefit of
doing really high rep ranges and this is
higher than you're going to achieve any
other way
ultimately you end up doing 20 30 40
repetitions but at the same time you can
still really challenge yourself by using
heavy
wait and yeah I think drop sets are
great and of course any type of force
breath is also gonna do the same thing
so you can do heavy curls and then cheat
to help yourself for assisted curls or
you can do bench press and then have a
friend assist
so anything that pushes you past failure
will allow you to train with heavy
weights but then also train for those
higher rep ranges to increase your
vascularity and if you're looking for
intensity techniques to increase
vascularity and pump then one of my
favorites is called burns so burns are
these really tiny partial reps that you
do once you can't do anymore so instead
of dropping the weight you're going to
do as much of the repetition as you
still can that might mean Curl Curl Curl
and then when you can't do anymore
you're literally just bobbing your arm
up not even coming up halfway and that
way you're really going past the point
of failure until you can barely even
move your arm and the pump you get from
that is crazy it also follows that doing
blood flow restriction training might
also increase your vascularity after all
it's said specific adaptations are
imposed in man's blood flow restriction
means that you have tying some kind of
tor nichette or other kind of band
around the top of the limb that you're
gonna be training so that the blood can
pull into the area as it's needed but
not return as easily this is cause this
causes blood to collect in that muscle
group and this has been suggested to
lead to hypertrophy and there are some
interesting studies suggesting that it
can be effective in that way and at the
same time it follows to me that this
might also increase vascularity
anecdotal reports suggest that it does
so it's certainly another way to get the
pump and singers chasing the pump is the
way that most of us think you increase
vascularity it makes sense you might as
well add this to the end of your
workouts
the way that most people use blood flow
restriction is to do their normal set
and then just do one step at the end
with a lightweight and light restriction
but that at the top of that muscle and
this work particularly well of course
for isolation movements not so much your
compound movements in fact one study
suggests that simply adding at or
nichette to your legs the tops of your
legs and then walking around is enough
to encourage hypertrophy because it
causes so much blood pooling that it
causes cells swelling basically that's
the basic idea behind it so in theory
maybe this could work for your arms as
well just roll up those sleeves with
some tie
two long-sleeved top and then you might
restrict your blood flow and who knows
trigger hypertrophy and certainly in the
short term this is a hack to get these
veins to start to pop if you just want
to look more vascular walking around so
you're welcome as well as vascular
smooth muscle our veins and arteries
also contain something called
endothelium cells and these have the job
among other things of producing nitric
oxide so nitric oxide is a substance
that causes vasodilation the veins to
dilate as it's needed in response to
things like adrenaline so this is why
when you're in a panic - fight-or-flight
state your body's able to design wreck
the blood flow where it's needed to the
muscles to the brain etc and increasing
nitric oxide is of course a way to
temporarily increase the visibility of
your veins and your arteries because it
makes them larger and this is why of
course many of us will take pre-workout
supplements containing things like
l-arginine and citrulline because this
causes vasodilation in order to get us
to feel more of a pump and make us look
more vascular during workouts of course
you can't always be walking around on
pre-workout you'd be pretty jittery and
also the effects a short-term but if you
take garlic and vitamin C then this has
been shown to increase nitric oxide by
up to 200 percent which is pretty
impressive this works because garlic is
high in nitrites which the tongue
bacteria on the tongue more specifically
converts into nitro team and actually
this is one reason why using a mouthwash
might be a bad thing vascularity because
you kill off the good bacteria that
cause this conversion at the same time
the vitamin C helps protect the nitric
oxide molecules once they're created so
this is a synergistic combination that
you can add to your diet vitamin C and
garlic of course have all kinds of other
positive benefits they're cheap they're
readily available so do that and you
might look more vascular throughout the
day at the same time beetroot juice has
been shown to increase vasodilation and
thereby also increase athletic
performance because of course having
wider blood vessels means more blood to
the muscles thereby meaning greater
performance and in studies beetroot
juice has been shown to improve athletic
performance in short term endurance
activities by 3% which doesn't sound
like a lot but it's an awful lot if
you're doing a short run for instance
where just a few seconds can make all
the difference but if it's boosting your
performance by increasing blood flow
that you're interested in then you
should be more concerned with your
capillaries so capillaries are not gonna
affect your aesthetics they're too small
in fact when they do come to a session
for skin they're that blue
fragile-looking blood vessels that you
don't want to see but these are the ones
that responsible for taking the
nutrients from your veins and into the
muscle and they're also responsible for
removing waste so the more of these you
have the more efficient you might be
during exercise and studies show that
the best ways to increase your capos
that's right you can actually create
more capillaries is through low
intensity steady-state cardio or high
intensity interval training so if you
want to increase your blood flow then
adding those to your routine could be
the best way to do that at the same time
it makes sense to me that this could
increase your vascularity because of
course if you have more capacity to fuel
the muscles with the blood then maybe
you're gonna have more blood flow go in
there
so to summarize these are the best
things to start doing if you want to
increase your vascularity train your
forearm muscles lose body fat train for
the pump tential ii by using intensive
techniques and drop sets prevent water
attention by drinking lots of water
throughout the day also make sure your
electrolyte balances on point and wait
for your skin to get thinner as you get
older using tourniquet training my oz be
useful increasing nitric oxide might be
useful and using steady-state cardio or
interval training might help to improve
blood flow and who knows that could also
increase your vascularity take we found
something useful there he did then
please consider leaving a like down
below it helps me massively check me out
on social media on Mon Instagram I'm on
Twitter and on Facebook all the links
down below head over to the blog where
I've got a more detailed version of this
discussion including all the links to
the references and the studies that you
need and comment down below let me know
what you think and if I missed anything
also let me know if you want to see any
other topics like this I know a lot of
you want to see me do stuff on neck
training so that's coming up got lots of
other cool ideas in the pipeline if you
want to make sure you see those then of
course subscribe thanks a ton for
watching so much I really
and I'll see you next time bye for now